lola bret
à 25 ans elle vient tout juste
d'accepter une mission
cela ne lui prendra qu'un quart d'heure
de son temps sur une journée déjà bien
chargé c'est une des toutes premières
renault 2,1 comprenez qu'elle assure des
livraisons pour une plateforme numérique
cette start up vient tout juste de se
créer
mr
c'est votre boulot quotidien non pas du
tout je suis étudiante à côté comédienne
et donc j'ai pu le temps de faire ou re
servent eux ça me permet d'arrondir mes
fins de mois
à l'aide d'un simple smartphone gogo run
run est en train de damner le pion aux
livreurs traditionnels l'application
permet à tout à chacun de se transformer
en coursier d'un jour mais ce job ne
permet pas de gagner beaucoup de l'été
mais combien pour cette force là c'est
une course à 5 euros
ses livres et 25% c'est la commission de
l'intermédiaire entre les coursiers et
leurs clients son fondateur tient se
démarquer du modèle américain dont tout
le monde parle du beurre c'est vrai
qu'on propose pour la première fois un
service de coursiers qu'on appelle des
runner accessible simplement pour les
particuliers c'est extrêmement simple
vous avez un iphone
bientôt un android vous pouvez
télécharger l'application ses proches du
modèle bar pub non parce que c'est tout
à fait légal
new york londres paris
uber annonce avoir transporté son
milliardième passagers
cette marque mondiale est devenue en
2015 un nom commun ou numérisation après
le bastion des taxis bousculé par les
vtc
aucun secteur n'est épargné
un déluge d'applications secret à la
frontière des réglementations établi
entre ces failles ou transforment en
détective privé avec lov docteur vous
consultez un médecin à distance alors
qu'avec testament taux plus besoin des
services d'un notaire
tout semble possible à portée d'un clic
de quoi donner le tournis
tout le monde a peur de se faire hubert
ise a même déclaré un patron français
mettez ce que cela veut dire
j'ai gardé thibault saint phalle est à
la tête du beurre en france son
entreprise est à l'origine de ce tsunami
numérique
elle bouleverse les positions établies
la réalité c'est que là on dans une
voiture avec un chauffeur on est deux
personnes on s'est mis en contact via
une application technologique mais un
rapport humain et c'est un moyen de
transport utile démocratique accessible
donc c'est très humain au fond donc oui
ça fait peur parce que ça transforme
vite mais en même temps c'est autant de
choses qui rentrent du temps genre de
l'argent créé du lien dans les jambes il
ya des choses positives dont on parle
peu on voit bien que beaucoup de
l'entreprise nous imitent et essayer de
reproduire notre succès innove par
dessus une imitation et donc on est
évidemment susceptibles de se faire une
vérité démarré à la mi temps on en est
ravi on devra juste réagir avec quoi
avec de l'innovation depuis son
lancement en 2012
bruno tboul ce spécialiste de l'économie
numérique utilisé lui aussi volontiers
ce service de berlines aux vitres
teintées en analysant ce que signifie
l'ubs et risation il a changé d'avis
les conséquences malheureusement elles
sont aussi parfois et peuvent être
extrêmement néfaste et dévastatrice
notamment sur l'emploi et sur les
conditions sociales
on va dire des gens qui sont aujourd'hui
employés si on peut appeler ça un emploi
en tout cas qui sont effectivement sous
forme contractuelle ou sous une autre
d'ailleurs en relation avec ces mêmes
plates formes qui sont qui se retrouve
finalement dans une relation plutôt
précaire pourtant dans ce centre
d'accueil chaque semaine des centaines
de chômeurs parient sur le fait il est
maintenant plus simple de trouver des
clients plutôt qu'un employeur c'est
pour produire à votre compte vous avez
votre assurance s'enregistrer comme
chauffeur chez über n'est qu'une étape
pour gaëtan menayas de juin beaucoup
plus qu'attendu
pourquoi
fâché le canal
donc les personnes qui chargeaient
travail est pour ça que les personnes
qui travaillent pour moi sont des gens
non par l'idéal c'est d'avoir six
véhicules qui 74 3 6 10 8
18 personnes et fait 1 objectifs qu'on
s'est fixés grand frère à partir de juin
le précieux sésame en poche ils sont
maintenant plus de 7000 conducteur à
circuler dans la capitale
c'est le marché le plus important en
dehors des états unis
jordan vous êtes des rallyes ce soir
chanter et du cruchon et l'un d'eux
salariés en céder une société de bus le
jour il est auto entrepreneurs la nuit
si vous désirez de l'eau des petites
friandises c'est pour vous
- confirmé l'adresse ensemble vous avez
bien drôle c'est à dire très bien c'est
bon bon sens comme une cerise sur le
gâteau du beurre ils ont achevé de
ringardiser l'image des taxis ça se
résume à l'eau
quelquefois le tour de paris
râleur voleurs chicaneur bonjour bonjour
vraiment la mauvaise image des 17000
taxi parisien est pourtant en train de
changer
pour riposter über eux aussi ont créé
une application géolocalisée afin
d'améliorer leurs services
derrière le volant hakim addad n un
chauffeur aux statuts différents
il fait partie d'une coopérative et à ce
titre il bénéficie d'une protection
sociale
on est mise de son chauffeur associés
alors chacun chacun est motivée en fait
on est pris par le dossier et chacun et
patrons et moi je compte sur les autres
chauffeurs parce que leur soient l'asile
le même service que moi on est à rennes
c'est une action c'est une société on a
des parts dans une société à l'accord
alors nous notre but c'est faire tourner
cette société sur la banquette arrière
l'écrivain laurent lasne il est le
chantre de la profession de taxi si
décrié sa cible uber pop
cette application permet à tout le monde
de se transformer en taxi interdite en
france depuis l'été dernier
cela reste l'exemple le plus flagrant de
libéralisation d'un secteur une
prédation selon lui
la valeur de marché du beurre
aujourd'hui c'est de l'ordre de 50 à 60
milliards de dollars dont vous voyez que
c'est une entreprise qui a beaucoup de
moyens
c'est une machine de guerre en quelque
sorte quelques instituts et humeur et
avec des arguments qui sont souvent
fallacieux on l'a vu notamment avec du
beurre pop c'est à dire que pour
conquérir un marché on n'hésite pas à
utiliser des moyens qui sont des moyens
là pour le compte de prédation puisque
on organise une concurrence qui est une
concurrence inégale
on fait travailler des chauffeurs
amateurs pour déstabiliser le marché
avec les nouvelles opportunités
économiques
les utilisateurs retiennent le mot
économie pour leur porte-monnaie les
startups airbnb blabla car ou encore oui
car est ce que ce sont elles aussi des
prédateurs ou des modèles d'économie
collaborative numérisation elle concerne
en fait deux types d' approche
une approche qui se veut beaucoup plus
orienté construction de plateformes de
type effectivement hyper capitaliste
parce que ce seront ceux sont des
acteurs qui vont lever des fonds
valoriser leur entreprise et est
finalement avoir envie de créer de la
valeur pour eux mêmes c'est à dire les
actionnaires plus que pour les salariés
donc d'un côté de numérisation la des
plateformes de type über airbnb et c'est
très capitalistique et puis est en train
de se construire une économie
collaborative coopératif solidaire et
sociale les deux renvoyant à une
économie plus large ou à une approche
plus globale qu'on pourrait qualifier
d'économie à la demande
90% du temps une voiture personnelle ne
roule pas partie de ce constat marion
carette a eu l'idée de oui car une plate
forme de location de voitures entre
particuliers
habituel pour une fondatrice d'utiliser
son propre système
ben oui c'est important pourquoi il faut
bien tester un peu savoir comment ça
marche savoir si les propriétaires sont
contents de comment ça comment ça
fonctionne c'est important de toute
l'équipe utilise les services de la
société
aujourd'hui oui on chantait jacques
olivier batty voilà la voiture et la
climatisation il ya pas qu ps le
principe est simple
louer sa voiture sans risque au lieu de
la laisser stationner dans la rue
voiture ce parisien propose la sienne
depuis deux mois seulement mais cela lui
a rapporté déjà 150 euros de quoi
l'entretenir social institue la patronne
est allé voir professionnel c'est leur
métier ils font ça ils font ça très bien
c'est déjà fait personnellement à faire
appel à eux
c'est un autre métier très différent
pour moi en tout cas de mon point de vue
par rapport à l'utilisation c'est
quelque chose qui reste vraiment
occasionnels finances justice santé pas
un domaine n'y échappe
des myriades de plateformes coco
comprenez de consommation collaborative
se développe tout ne survivront pas
mais chacun de ces nouveaux coco prétend
révolutionner l'économie à la papa avec
en tête la réussite du modèle über eu
peur ce n'est pas de l'économie
collaboratif c'est vrai que on se
reconnaît bien dans tous et dans toutes
ces choses là mobilité partagée
le fait de ballades réservé sur son
mobile etc
oui ça c'est des choses qui peuvent
s'appliquer non mais on fait plus partie
de la consommation collaborative que que
d'autres choses finalement c'est
quasiment la troisième révolution
industrielle parce que on arrive dans
une économie c'est vraiment les gens
gagnent de l'argent etc mais qui est
basé sur
plutôt que posséder on va on va plutôt
utiliser la fonctionnalité finalement de
l'objet on a on a tous des ressources
inutilisées interdire ou encadrer sidéré
par l'ampleur et la rapidité du
phénomène
les pouvoirs publics ont longtemps
hésité aujourd'hui on estime que plus de
700 mille sites dits commerce exercera
en europe
pourtant à peine un millier est inscrit
auprès de l'administration fiscale en
france
les parlementaires ont décidé de contre
attaquer aujourd'hui une personne
qui va louer un appartement ne sait pas
forcément qu'il doit faire une
déclaration ne connaît pas forcément le
montant de ce qu'il doit déclarer ne
connais pas non plus les exonérations
auquel il a droit
la plate forme demain sera obligé de
donner ces informations
et deuxièmement la plateforme va être
appelé à donner à chaque acteur de
l'économie collaboratif quel est le
chiffre d'affaires qu'ils ont dégagé sur
une année il ne s'agit pas encore une
fois d'aller taxer le particulier qui va
vendre un produit d'occasion sur
internet sur le bon coin
si quelqu'un effectivement décide de
partager sa voiture pour effectuer un
paris-lyon c'est pas ça qu'on cherche à
taxer ni à interdire ça serait
complètement absurde par contre pour
ceux qui ont un appartement deux
appartements et qui les louent à l'année
sans rien déclarer c'est pas possible on
a la même chose avec les loueurs de
voitures les grands loueurs de voitures
que nous que nous avons rencontrés nous
ont expliqué aujourd'hui ils ne sont
plus les premiers loueurs ce sont des
volumes des particuliers qui ont parfois
dix quinze vingt véhicules à louer en
dehors de toutes les règles et ça ça ne
peut pas continuer ainsi
si rien n'est fait des dizaines de
milliards d'euros pour échapper à
l'impôt
difficile pourtant de légiférer quand on
est soi même un utilisateur fasciné vous
avez déménagement livraison garde
d'enfants location et près des objets
tâches ménagères
c'est des gens qui très simple
je vous dire la vérité c'est que c'est
un milieu qui reste jeune milieu
gérontocratie prime sur tout le reste
moi ça me permet de voir aussi notre
monde j'ai l'impression après 1968
c'était ma révolutionnaire le système
économique est partagée est totalement
révolutionnaire
je me devais d'y aller